Beautiful wife
Do you know what the most terrifying part
of a heart attack is?
I know
You'll die very soon.
That's right, I'll teach you
one acupoint right away.
When you feel discomfort
in your heart and shortness of breath
Save yourself immediately.
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Six thousand people died suddenly from myocardial infarction.
one Acupoint for Quick Self-Rescue
More than 6,000 people die suddenly each year
in Taiwan due to acute myocardial infarction.
How to help yourself if you have heart discomfort
I want to share with you
A useful acupoint for emergency treatment
That is the jí quán (transliteration) acupoint.
It is specially designed to help you
Relieves palpitations and rapid heartbeat
The jí quán (transliteration) acupoint.is located in the middle of the armpit.
You pinch thejí quán (transliteration) acupointwith your fingers.
Then press down on the pectoralis major muscle with the other hand.
Pull it like this.
felt a slight pain.
That's fine.
Pressing the jí quán (transliteration) acupoint
It allows blood
to flow back to the heart quickly
Reduce stress on the heart
and stabilize blood pressure
Even you
In a critical moment
Like chest tightness and a racing heart.
Even situations where someone nearby falls
into a coma
can rely on this trick
Save your own life
Of course, it can also save other people's lives.
Very practical
I need to learn this quickly.
Yes, good
Myocardial infarction tends to affect 4 types of people
one Exercise test for vascular elasticity
Did you know?
Myocardial infarction is the second leading cause
of death in Taiwan.
That's terrifying!
Right
Let's look at who is prone
to myocardial infarction.
These four types of people
The first type is people in their fifties or sixties.
People with high blood pressure, high blood sugar, or high cholesterol, or a family history of these conditions
The third type is people with poor lifestyle habits.
Factors such as smoking, overwork, and chronic insomnia
These high-risk groups
The fourth type is infection or inflammation.
Large temperature difference
can also easily trigger myocardial infarction.
That myocardial infarction
Can I test myself?
It can detect the elasticity of your blood vessels
and the condition of your circulation.
To see if blood vessels are healthy or unhealthy
Come on, clench your fist
for a few seconds
and then immediately release it.
Observe the color of the palm
How fast does it recover?
If within three seconds
Able to restore original skin color
Congratulations! Your blood vessels are quite elastic.
However, the recovery time is quite long.
This indicates that the blood vessels
may be relatively hard
and inelastic, making them prone to arteriosclerosis.
Or the risk of poor circulation.
Taking a shower immediately upon returning home is not allowed.
3 ways to keep warm and protect your heart
Did you know that blood vessels constrict
when the weather gets cold?
Blood pressure can rise instantly.
Risk of heart disease and acute stroke
And so it increased.
I'll teach you three ways to stay warm.
Learn it quickly
First tip: Don't go straight into the bathroom when you get home
Why
Taking a hot shower causes a sudden
and drastic change in body temperature.
Vasodilation
It is very dangerous for people
with cardiovascular problems.
Let's drink a glass of warm water first.
Warm up your body?
Very smart
Turn on the bathroom heater
after you've drunk hot water.
Turn on the hot water and wait until the bathroom is warm
before you go in to take a shower.
Taking a bath in winter
Is there anything should be aware of?
Do not soak in the bath
for more than ten minutes.
Soaking for too long can easily cause dizziness.
It's easy to fall and it's very dangerous.
Second tip: Keep warm immediately after taking a shower
You leave the bathroom after showering.
Exposure to cold air can cause blood vessels
to constrict
potentially triggering a myocardial infarction or stroke.
Someone came out of the bathroom after taking a shower.
Stepping onto the icy floor
Result headache
The right side of body, including arms and legs, feels weak.
Speech is unclear
was rushed to the hospital after suffering a stroke.
Is it that serious?
After taking a shower, you must
Hurry up and put your clothes on.
Yes, you must pay attention.
The third tip: Place warm clothing by the bed.
Getting up to use the bathroom in the middle of the night
Or when get up in the morning
First, warm up your hands and feet.
Get out of bed slowly
Put the clothes next to the pillow
Or somewhere that can be reached out and touched immediately
Available anytime, keeping warm and safe.
Next, an advertisement.
Four hundred days of waiting
Just for this one sip of essence
Yù tài bái (transliteration) Soy Sauce
Pingtung Old Shop's 70-Year Heritage
Japanese fully wet construction method
Continue fermentation for 400 days
Makes the aroma of soybean and wheat sauce more mellow and sweet.
soy sauce
Choose the original flavor for the best taste.
White soy sauce ingredients are simple
Soybeans, wheat, salt
Sugar Rice
No added preservatives, fragrances, or colorings
Natural Safety
Only the first amber-colored original juice is used.
Quality is guaranteed through multiple certifications.
Yù tài bái (transliteration) Soy Sauce is best suited for enhancing the flavor of dishes.
It's not very salty
Only then can you taste the true deliciousness.
sashimi or dumplings
Dipping it in Whitesoy sauce best brings out its refreshing and delicious flavor.
Refreshing and delicious
Use Whitesoy sauceto tenderize braised meat.
It melts in your mouth
Overflowing with the aroma of soy sauce
Dipping sauce, stew, and braised dishes are all good.
Cold Tofu Salad
Blanched vegetables
Add a little flavor and it's instantly upgraded.
Yù tài bái (transliteration) Soy Sauce
Awaken the taste of home in your memory
with the pure and wonderful flavor of traditional soy sauce.
Sleeping too little or not sleeping well can damage your heart.
Increased risk of myocardial infarction by 1.69 times
Did you sleep well last night?
Poor sleep or too little sleep
heart
might just go on strike.
People who don't get enough sleep, take note!
Research shows
Every night
People who sleep less than 5 hours
The risk of myocardial infarction
1.56 times higher for people who sleep 7 to 8 hours
compared to those who sleep 7 to 8 hours.
More than 1.5 times!
People with insomnia
Even 1.69 times higher
Wow, that's about 1.7 times!
People who always have trouble sleeping
Press an acupoint before going to bed
It is the Shenmen acupoint.
On the wrist crease
Between the little finger and the ring finger
On the connecting line of this line
Press each hand for one or two minutes.
Helps calm your mind
Sleep better faster
I'm going to sleep.
Do you think young people
who stay up all night won't get into trouble?
A college student
He has a tendency towards high blood pressure and diabetes.
But he loves staying up all night playing games.
They played day and night during summer vacation.
The diet is a mess
He was only in his early twenties.
He actually had a stroke.
This story is not an isolated case.
Good sleep
It is the best health care product for the heart
The more we sleep
Is it better to be better?
This matter is not as simple
as a fool might think.
It's not true that the more you sleep, the better.
People who sleep 6 hours a night
Risk of myocardial infarction
It's even lower than people
who sleep more than 9 hours!
Black fungus plus 2 ingredients
Stay away from stroke and myocardial infarction
Want to improve blood flow
and prevent stroke and myocardial infarction?
I recommend a drink
that's both delicious and good for your heart.
Black fungus, red dates, and old ginger dew
Recorded in the Compendium of Materia Medica
Black fungus promotes blood circulation and stops bleeding.
It can inhibit platelet aggregation
Preventing arteriosclerosis
Red dates contain
cAMP
It can dilate coronary blood vessels
Improve myocardial nutrition
Enhance contractile force
Prevention of myocardial infarction
and heart weakness
along with old ginger,Huó xuè xǐng xuè (transliteration)
The entire blood vessel was then cleared.
Very smooth
Then the heart will be healthier.
Dear friends, here are the detailed ingredients and instructions
for making this black fungus, red date, and ginger soup.
I will put it last
Take a screenshot of it tonight.
Let's try cooking it tomorrow.
3 Drinks That Are Most Harmful to the Heart
Cardiovascular risk surges by 42%
Do you often drink beverages?
Fruit juice, sugary drinks, alcohol
Drinking too much of these three beverages
It not only hurts your heart, but it also damages your blood vessels!
Let's start with juice.
I suggest you eat fruit
instead of drinking juice.
Think about it.
Do you usually eat
three or four oranges at a time?
No way.
No way, right?
A glass of juice is made of
It was extracted from many oranges.
It's very high in sugar.
American research points out
Drinking high-sugar fruit juice every day
More than one cup
The risk of developing cardiovascular disease
is 42% higher
for those who drink it than for those who don't.
The second sugary drink
Do you drink sugary drinks
more than three times a week?
Bubble tea, soft drinks, energy drinks, coffee smoothies
What will get?
The editor says
will be happy.
Of course will be happy!
But drank too much
body is unhappy
Excessive sugar intake
can cause drastic fluctuations in blood sugar.
Weight increased
European research found
Did you know
that people who drink more than two cups of soda a day
The risk of death is 17% higher
for those who consume
less than one cup per month.
Cardiovascular disease mortality rate is 52% higher.
These sugars
can raise triglyceride levels.
That is, elevated triglycerides.
This increases the burden on blood vessels.
In the long run
heart is working so hard.
The third type of beverage: alcoholic beverages.
Do you like to drink red wine or spirits at night?
Long-term alcohol consumption can numb the body
It's a major enemy of the heart!
It can cause high blood pressure, stroke, and alcoholic cardiomyopathy.
People with arrhythmia
It may also worsen heart palpitations.
When I was young
He also loves drinking zhú yè qīng (transliteration) liquor.
Falling asleep quickly
But...
If suddenly wake up in the middle of the night
Then tossing and turning
just couldn't fall asleep anymore.
In the long run
It has no benefits for the cardiovascular system whatsoever.
These three beverages
It's really best to drink less.
How to make black fungus, red dates, and ginger soup
1-2 fresh black fungus
6 slices of old ginger
15 red dates
1200cc of water
Make two cuts on the red dates with a knife.
Add all the ingredients: black fungus, old ginger, etc.
Place in the inner pot of the electric rice cooker
Add 1200cc of water
Add 1.5 cups of water
to the outer pot of the electric rice cooker.
Press the switch to cook
After the switch pops up
can enjoy it directly.
Alternatively,
remove the ginger slices
and put the ingredients from the pot into a blender.
Blend until thick.
can drink it.
People who want something sweeter
You can add an appropriate amount of sugar.
Dear fans
We have launched the membership channel.
If you agree with my promotion of Traditional Chinese Medicine
The concept of taking care of one's own health
Small monthly donations are welcome.
It only costs the price of two cups of coffee!
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you by my side
Only then can we go further.
Thank you so much!